faudrait un quota de vous aviez dit je
sais plus 4 j'ai fait le calcul alors
attendez je vais dire de 4 ou 5 vols
dans une ville où chacun d'entre nous
est-ce que vous vous maintenez cela ou
est-ce que vous avez évolué non depuis
j'ai fait les calculs c'est à peu près
le bonheur de grandeur que ce truc qui
paraît aujourd'hui inconcevable
restrictif malthusien triste cirque
bonbon et j'en passe à une partie des
gens qui réagissent il faut bien que ils
se rendent compte que c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement récent et qui
partira avec le pétrole parce que quand
on regarde les alternatives techniques
au pétrole dans l'aviation de toute
façon une fois qu'il y aura plus de
pétrole il y aura pas de quoi assurer
quatre vols dans une vie par terrien
c'est pas grave alors
ils veulent punir et privé une
génération de jeunes qui n'a rien
demandé qui ne pourra plus voyager puis
découvrir plus faire de business aussi
économiquement ce serait dramatique et
ensuite ce qui est doublement
insupportable c'est que cette génération
de personnes qui nous font la leçon ils
ont tous 60 ans ou plus à 61 ans donc
eux ils ont vécu la vida loca ils ont
pris comme des ports et nous on doit
rester enfermés chez nous et manger du
quinoa pour prendre la voiture et pas
prendre l'avion c'est insupportable
manquerait plus qu'il t'empêchait de
pédicure
mais je suis prêt à respecter je veux
comme interdise de prendre l'avion je
veux qu'on m'interdise de laisser une
empreinte carbone démesurée il faut
faire attention c'est en agit pas
Guillaume la terre elle est morte la
viande c'est 8% du pétrole mondial
est-ce qu'on a besoin de ce qu'on peut
pas demander à chacun avec vous allez
ralentir votre consommation d'avion si
on légitaire pas jamais
bénabarit jamais il y a que la menace
qui marche avec vous
on a encore une de nos une de nos
dernières industries c'est l'industrie
aéronautique tu vas mettre sur le
carreau notre dernier industrie
son vent la terre c'est clair
je veux la sauver sauver la Terre
qu'est-ce qui est en train de faire
l'industrie aéronautique elle est en
train de devenir beaucoup plus verte
donc au lieu de au lieu de culpabiliser
de dire arrêtons tout on est en train de
prendre
tu
mets tu mets tout un secteur au chômage
au lieu de dire les
responsabilisons-nous les uns les autres
sauvons la terre mais là n'empêche pas
l'autre c'est ça qui est incroyable avec
toi alors rien n'empêche pas
mon enfant il habite au Brésil par
exemple donc je fais dire adieu comment
la Terre et ben voilà voilà
excusez-moi les caractéristiques
individuels n'ont pas lieu d'être Cyril
je suis désolé c'est un effort collectif
qu'il faut aussi Jean-Marie voit pas son
enfant tant pis
c'est pas parce que tu vas pas ta meuf
qui va pas marcher donc ça veut dire que
tu arrêtes d'aller au Sénégal tous les
étés
mais je suis prêt à obéir voilà je suis
prêt que l'écologie punitive ça va dans
le mur en fait
quand on ouvre sa gueule
est-ce que ça peut emprunter
4 fois dans l'année
qu'est-ce que tu es drôle
c'est tout bah oui c'est tout non mais
c'est la voiture
un aller-retour ça compte deux fois les
deux voyages
par exemple
il a décidé il nous dit en gros ça sera
deux fois quand on est jeune deux fois
quand on est vieux quand est-ce qu'on
arrête d'être jeune alors qu'il va
décider à 35 à 30 ans les études pour
s'ouvrir
que ça vous détournez son propos voilà
c'est quelqu'un de très sensible pas du
tout merci moi je suis pour sauver la
Terre voilà et pas du tout moi je suis
pour sauver ta meuf là ça
non mais il y a une forme de régression
dans ce que dissident c'est un travail
qui veulent convive comme les hommes des
cavernes ça pour voyage plus rien qu'on
prenne plus la voiture c'est une
décroissance économiquement sur Internet
voilà c'est ça
et les bateaux les paquebots arrêtez de
prendre le bateau parce que vous vous
faites chier avec les avions bien sûr je
vais redire encore une fois ici
un paquebot un paquebot un million de
voitures une société de paquebot le
parcours européen de toutes les voitures
qui est en Europe une 60 paquebots c'est
toutes les voitures en Europe alors
bloque-moi déjà 60 plaque d'eau paquebot
et après on peut pas être bon des
pagesblanes
arrête le téléphone arrête le téléphone
ici
les chiens perdus que tu viens de voir
ici alors le chien il a été perdu tu as
bien fait une enquête tu bosses les
fiches tout ça c'est mon téléphone
tu l'as bien trouvé ton téléphone ici
sauvons la terre et ne m'emmerdez pas
voilà et tu as beaucoup de feuilles de
papier c'est responsable de la
piratation
et Daniel a dit oui regardez 15 kg de
carton là 15 kg de carton tous les jours
je n'ai pas de voiture et le téléphone
le plus grand voyage qu'elle a fait
c'est en monte-escalier cette année
électrique
la batterie du la batterie de ton
monte-escalier il y a un vrai problème
un qui à Paris un tiers de l'empreinte
carbone vient des avions donc c'est un
vrai problème je suis désolé évidemment
volontiers provocateur alors d'abord je
Jean-Marie je t'offre mes 8 voyages tu
pourras aller voir ton film je te
remercie au Brésil c'est pas vrai
moi je pose comme une espèce de cartes à
point parce qu'en fait notre esprit
écologique s'arrête là où ça nous
arrange plus le cauchemar non mais faut
être faut pas
par exemple
parce que j'en ai peur vous avez l'air
de souffrir ah ouais j'ai sauté là je me
suis dit
c'est quoi je suis en train de crever
tout le monde s'en
foutez de la glace déjà mettez de la
glace déjà d'urgence
trimballer les bombes comme ça faut les
emmener à la main
ça va être terrible
ça veut dire que les jeunes plus
personne n'ira voir ce qui se passe hors
des frontières
on va pas rencontrer d'autres cultures
on reste enfermé
par le sujet c'est-à-dire que les jets
privés sont pas concernés dans le même
c'est-à-dire complètement ailleurs vous
allez vous en [__] complètement
pas tout de suite on aura déjà perdu
Daniel entre nous donc concentrez-vous
déjà sur ce que vous pouvez faire
maintenant bien sûr on verra donc me
cassez pas la mise à jour électrique ça
sera déjà électrique
c'est vraiment
qu'elle a dépassé encore à
l'électricités
vous êtes fous quoi tout le monde m'a
demandé l'électricité alors mais
qu'est-ce que tu crois tu me demandes à
moi je vous demande des professions ça
fait 10 ans qu'on est à l'électrique les
mecs
pourquoi les bus sont pas électriques
pourquoi toutes les professions qui
roulent électrique
tu peux faire 400 km avec une batterie
tu vas pas me dire que le bus il fait
pas 400 km fait que des allers-retours
de 20 km arrête arrête ça fait 40000 si
tu fais 20 km à un moment donné il
s'arrête de rouler au bout de 3h et tu
prends un autre bus vous êtes mais non
mais réagissez il y avait des bus
électriques avant et il y avait des bus
électrique avant ils les ont arrêté et
maintenant c'est des bus à l'hydrogène
ou c'est des bus au colza l'électricité
n'a pas marché colza ah non attendez je
mets un coup de pied dans la fourmis il
a besoin de parler ce soir
on était à Roland Garros
vous avez prévu il m'a dit sur la tête
de ma mère qu'est-ce que tu m'as dit
Roland
Ellie je vais être marbré ce soir mais
lisez me donne pas la parole regarde
regarde les carabines de partout
j'ai fait un malaise
il est allé on était à Roland Garros il
est parti
allez le
bois toi pour moi pour moi c'était là